so I talked about online algorithms with
recourse so this is not a new model it
has been around for a while but just
that I think a lot of recent work has
happened and a lot of open problems
remain so let me just begin by going
over how we define competitive analysis
so we say that you have some problem and
an input arrives over time and at each
time T I want to maintain a solution
over whatever input I have seen so far
and then whatever decisions I have taken
so far they are in some sense
irrevocable that's the assumption and
the way I analyze my algorithm is by
comparing it with something which knows
the entire input in advance right so we
say that look at the best offline
algorithm and I should be comparable to
that right and then I define the
competitive ratio of another algorithm
on on an input sequence as cost of my
solution by the compare to the best of
optimal solution okay so uh so it's let
me give an example
so I'll talk about this problem called
online load balancing so what happens
here is that at each point of time
one job arrives okay and think of it as
a unit size job and the job arrives it
can only be processed on a subset of
machines okay so it specifies which
subset of machines it can be processed
on so for example this one can go on a
first two machines only and then you
send it to one of the machines and the
next job arrives and so on and I define
and then the idea is that the jobs that
I have already assigned they cannot be
reassign so that's the second point
that I cannot really change my solution
at each point of time and the goal is to
let's say minimize the maximum load on
the machine so not on the machine is how
many jobs you have sent on the machine
so look at all the machines and take max
of node on each machine okay let's see
you just want to minimize this so this
problem has been studied very well for a
long period of time and we know that if
you look at the grid er
it says that when a job arrives look at
all the machines it can go on and just
let's say assign it on the least loaded
machine okay so that's a natural
algorithm so let's say here it goes to
that machine so we know that this
algorithm is log am competitive where m
is the number of machines and in fact
this is also the best possible one can
do let me talk about a simpler version
of this problem which is and look at
okay even this version turns out to be
interesting so the simpler version is is
a special case when each job can only go
on two machines okay so and all you have
to do is to figure out which of the two
machines to set it on so I can think of
it as some sort of edge orientation
problem yes job is come job is in its
eyes and completely when it comes it
specifies which machines it can go to
okay so let's say think of machines as
vertices in a graph and each job is like
an edge okay and all you have to do is
to orient this edge okay so let's see
orient like this and so on okay and the
load is like the degree of a node so you
want to minimize the maximum degree of a
vertex if you think of the setting when
the underlying graph is a tree then I
claim that you can get optimum one
because you can just look at a root and
then just orient everything away from it
but even in this very simple case of
edge orientation then the underlying
graph being a tree one can show that the
best in online algorithm can do is like
log in okay why let's see so let's say
these are the nodes in the graph and
suppose some edge arrives and you orient
it in some manner okay
and then another edge arrives you orient
it like this and so on okay and then
another edge arrives which looks like
this the way I set it up is that its
endpoints are are the vertices which
already have in degree one and then you
do the same thing again right so two
vertices get in degree two now and then
you send an edge which connects the two
things and so on okay
so you can easily see that if I keep on
this I can make the in degree of some
vertex to be log M where m is the number
of vertices here and this I mean so this
shows a lower bound one can also show a
lower one for randomized algorithms and
it follows that the same lower bound
carries over to load balancing because
it's only a more difficult problem okay
and this is another problem that I will
talk about so this is called online
spanning tree so what happens here is
that you're given a metric space and
let's say what he sees arrived online
and all I have to do is to maintain a
spanning tree on all of the vertices
okay so let's say about XV 0 arrives and
at each time a new vertex VI arrives and
when it arrives it reveals to you the
distances to all the other points and
then you have to figure out how to
connect it to the remaining points and
again the idea is that you're not really
allowed to change the tree that you
already have because you know then by by
our definition we are not going to do
that ok so let's say even arrives you
connect it like this v2 arrives and so
on ok and then you want to minimize the
cost of the tree ok so it just a simple
MST problem ok and I can think of the
greedy algorithm which says that when a
vertex arrives you connect it to the
nearest vertex right so v1 arrives v2
goes to the nearest one and so on and it
is known that this algorithm is a log n
competitive and there is also a matching
lower bound of log n so in some sense
log n is the right bound
ok so so let me just sort of you know
review like what are the what the point
is that the the idea of using
competitive analysis has been very
successful in analyzing lot of
algorithms which are actually used in
practice but like routing network design
and so on but often it turns out to be
quite pessimistic so for example in
these settings we see that sometimes you
can be as far as log N
the optimum also their other extreme
settings where the combinative less
equal to even be unbounded and in such
cases it is not clear how to proceed
because how do you compare two different
algorithms let's say if the competitive
ratio can be very large okay so this was
the sort of the definition of using
comparative analysis and what I want to
look at is you know can I make can I
relax this this notion of irrevocable
okay can i sometimes say that some of my
past decisions can be changed so so this
this is what I want to look at okay if
you think about it it's not a valid
assumption I mean it is a valid
assumption in many cases for example if
you are looking at scheduling caching
paging I mean page faults which have
occurred you cannot do anything about
them similarly if there's a job that you
have processed then you cannot just go
back and say that I want to process it
again right so sometimes decisions which
you take in the past cannot be revoked
okay but maybe in some other settings it
is possible to change some of the
decisions that you have taken so far so
for example in the kind of problems I
was talking about it may appear as some
sort of temporary disruptions of
services for example you have built a
network and you want to say that look
things are getting bad so I just all I
want to do is I want to tweak some of
the edges in the graph okay so it may be
no overhead thing provided you don't
disrupt too many things okay so so for
example in the age of orientation
problem maybe I want to say that look
this is how I had assigned my jobs but
maybe I want to change some of the edge
orientations okay I want to go back and
you know it's I realize that some of the
orientations were bad so I want to go
back and change some of these okay and
then even imagine that there is a
trade-off between how much you change
your solution versus what's the
objective value okay
of course if I is resolved the problem
at every point of time I can be equal to
opt but then I will be changing my
solution a lot
so so this is the idea I want to explore
that items let's say I'm allowed to
change some of the past decisions okay
so for example in load-balancing I'm
saying that if you have done the
assignment of jobs I'll allow you to
reassign some of the jobs so for example
suppose these are the sex machines and
this is the current assignment of jobs
then a new job arrives and let's say it
goes to some machine but then I'll
perhaps maybe move around some other
jobs also so that you know the overall
load remains balanced okay maybe it will
help okay okay so similarly Network
design in routing we can say that I'll
read out some of the existing demands
and so on this line of work has
connections to this whole area of
dynamic graph algorithms where they say
that I want to maintain a good solution
I'll change my solution but at each
point of time
I'm not bounded by how much you change
but how much time you take so let's say
you take time T to change to figure out
the new solution then clearly in some
sense you're not changing your solution
too much by more than some function of T
so there there are connections to
dynamic online algorithms but but I will
not give go into the details here
okay so this is the plan huh I'll talk
about the edge orientation problem even
though it's a very simple problem turns
out that they're interesting open
questions here
then I'll see what happens in load
balancing I'll talk about standard tree
and then I'll conclude with some open
questions in okay so let's see what's
known here it's a very simple problem
and of course if you do naive which is
basically solve the problem at each
point of time you could be doing n
reorientation per unit time greedy as we
saw is is log M competitive it doesn't
have to do any changes in the solution
so broaden and forget about showed in 98
that you could get max in degree to the
instead of 1 provided you are allowed to
do 3 reorientation spur as arrival ok by
amortize I mean that at some point of
time it will do lot of orientations as
compared to other times but on an
average you will be only doing three
orientations per per unit time okay so
whenever the edge arrives I'm allowed to
change three other edges okay so that's
the that's the point okay so okay so let
me let me present the algorithm it's a
very extremely simple algorithm and has
a cute analysis so let's say this is the
situation okay the energy arrives which
connects these two vertices and what
they do is they say that let's just
orient it in in any manner okay okay and
now what I do is I see if some vertex
gets in degree 3 okay so I'm maintaining
the fact that nobody has in degree more
than 3 or 3 or more and now when you are
in this edge some vertex gets in degree
3 so what you do is you flip all the
incoming edges to it ok so I flip all
these three edges okay now what this may
do is you can imagine that some other
vertex may get in degree 3 because I
changed several edges now so then you do
the same thing at so whenever you see a
vertex was in degree becomes 3
you just flip all the edges coming to it
okay and this could lead to a cascade ok
so this for example that suppose there
was a vertex like that and the situation
was like that then you flip all the
three it is there okay and so on okay
and now I want to prove that on average
you will only do a constant number of
flips so so consider time T okay and
let's say that that's the optimal
solution and I'm saying that the the
underlying graph is a tree but need not
be a tree but let's say the opt is opt
is 1 and the underlying graph is a tree
doesn't matter okay and so that's the
optimal solution there okay and this is
your current solution at some point of
time you have not seen all the edges and
you have oriented your edges in some
manner so far ok and what I'm going to
show is that you know you you pick the
time T and I want to show that the total
number of flips that you do till this
time T is at most 3ds that that's what I
want to show so what I'll do is I'll
define a potential function so the okay
so let's have one definition I'll call
an edge in my solution to be a good edge
if it's orientation matches the optimal
tree orientation so remember this tree
is not changing with time it's fixed so
so your edge is good if it matches the
orientation in that tree otherwise it is
bad ok
and now so these two are voltages and
the other two are balances and now let's
define my potential as the number of bad
edges at any point of time ok so number
of edges which are oriented the wrong
way and what happens when a new edge
arrives with a new edge arrives you give
it some orientation so your if I could
go up by one unit but I claim that each
time you do a flip you will reduce the
potential why because you're flipping
three edges now out of those three edges
if you think about the optimal solution
only one of those was coming into this
vertex so you're setting at least to bad
I just do good ok so Phi is at least
decreasing by one unit ok and that shows
that you cannot be doing this operation
multiple times a lot of times ok ok so
that's it so that's that's the complete
proof ok and it
so that's that's what is known one
interesting open question which remains
is in this algorithm you are kind of you
may be doing a lot of flips at some
point of time so let's say I restrict
that you can only do let's say 10 flips
at each point of time so can now one get
a competitive ratio of constant so
that's not even known for a tree so even
if the line graph is a tree can I can I
prove that I can get an on amortized
constant comma constant okay interesting
open question is what if I am allowed to
even sort of delete edges okay so let's
say the graph will I guarantee you that
the graph will remain a tree but at each
point of time and either add an edge or
remove an edge and again I want let's
say constant amortized constant
competitive okay I should add that for
all of these problems if you are willing
to do log M amortized that is change log
M edges then one can get a constant
competitive Ryle else I will show the
citation later okay all right let's come
back and load balancing it's a slightly
harder problem and let's see what what
one can do here now it's not just an
edge orientation problem so the similar
kind of analysis will not work here so
recall that this was the problem that
you have to assign a job to one of the
machines and now we're trying to
understand what's the trade-off between
the competitive ratio and the extent of
reassignment that I need to do so this
is what is known so if you do greedy we
know let's log in competitive now note
that matching is a special case of this
problem because if opt is one that is
you can assign all the jobs to machines
where nobody gets two jobs so that's
this so the maximum matching is a
special case of this problem and both
psych eval showed that if you want to
maintain a maximum matching let's say at
each point of time then one needs one
can get away with doing only square root
n amortized reassignment okay
so even this is a highly non-trivial
result so our bucket I'll showed that if
you want for competitive algorithm then
one can get away with this log M changes
pair arrival when a job arrives you will
reassign log M jobs and we showed that
one can get a constant competitive
algorithm with constant number of
reassignments it also add that this is a
the case for maximum matching the
conjectured value here is log n we don't
know if that is true so Chaudry and
others showed that one can get a log n
reassignment result here provided the
input arrives in a random order but but
it remains an open problem to get log in
here okay so let me just describe what
this algorithm is which gets a constant
comma constant in in both the parameters
so this is for the random variable the
online case I know I don't think number
of changes not necessarily the time to
find the changes you want to maintain M
right you can extend this problem to the
case of general processing times and
then we get a log log and competitive
algorithm so you can again ask the same
question jobs have sizes instead of just
being unit size jobs and when we get
analog we can get a log log and
completive algorithm with constant
number of reassignments so so Allah
briefly described what the ideas here
are okay so the idea is very simple
let's say opt is one okay so let's say
it's possible to maintain a matching and
I'm allowed to put two jobs on a
particular machine so when a new job
arrives what I'll do is I'll find some
sort of shortest augmenting it so I'll
say that find a sequence of exchanges
which does not violate the load by two
and find the shortest such sequence of
exchanges because it's just a shortest
augmenting path problem so let's say
this job arrives you put it here because
load doesn't go beyond two but let's say
a job of that type of rice then you put
it here and then you may have to move it
further so I call it shortest augmenting
sequence and the idea of the proof is
the following that let's say that I
build a graph on the machines and I have
an edge between two machines if there is
a job on machine five which can go on
machine to look is that just the the
graph or the residual graph here okay
and I can I can look at this graph and
then I say that look if I want to move a
job from a particular machine I can
define you know the shortest path from
that machine to a vacant machine so this
this I'll call as the height of a
machine okay so height of a machine is
defined as the length of the shortest
augmenting path starting from this
machine okay and let mi denote the
number of machines whose height is I
now what I claim is that the size of mi
is exponentially small with respect to i
okay so sigh the number of machines of
height I is at most the number of
machines of height I - 1 / - okay
so it decreases exponentially let's say
height exactly i doesn't yeah it doesn't
matter you know maybe at most I will say
okay and then the proof is as follows
yeah maybe it should be at most I yes
okay so let's say there's a machine
let's the machine number 5 which has
height I and remember it has height ayah
means that there must be two jobs
sitting on it because if there was just
one job it site would be zero so there
are two jobs sitting on it let's say a
and B and look at the optimal solution
in the optimal solution these two jobs a
and B when perhaps going to machine
number two and machine number eight and
I claim that those two machines would
have height I minus one or more cannot
be having height i minus 1 i because if
they had very small height then 5 will
also have height very small okay so the
fact that five is height i means that
two and eight have height at least i
minus 1 right and and so that that kind
of doubling allows you to prove this
theorem ok so i'm not giving a formal
proof but that's the idea ok and then
one shows that the height of a machine
never decreases over time so this is a
property of the shortest augmenting path
algorithm ok so once you have all of
this what do I get I get that if you
look at the total amount of augmentation
that if you go to a machine of height I
you spend I units of time to do find the
find an empty machine okay so it's I
times size of MI which is order M right
because the size of mi is extremely
small ok so so that's the idea of the
proof we could extend it to flows where
we say that instead of just jobs being
assigned
machines requests are arriving in a
network and you want to route this
request to a to a source okay and then
the and then we can say that instead of
obeying the capacities you allow to
violate the capacities by a constant
factor when we also look at node
balancing with general job sizes this is
what I was referring to and one can get
a log-log and competitive algorithm here
let me just give you the brief idea of
what this algorithm which is log is for
general job sizes so now I claim that
just using a shortest augmenting path is
not good why because let's say a new job
arrives and you place it on some machine
then you may have to sort of send two
jobs away to just to balance the load
because the arriving job was a huge job
so you cannot say that I will just
change things along a single path you
may have to do it on a tree kind of
thing ok so I mean our first idea is to
just sort of think of some sort of
fractional version of this problem
so you break each long job into unit
size jobs and think of just scheduling
those unit size jobs the only thing you
have to do is that you have to change
the previous analysis where because if
you have split a job into multiple
pieces then moving a small piece should
cost less than one ok so whatever
fraction it is lets you have one third
of a job then I'll say that moving this
small piece will only cost one third ok
so given that one can look at the
fractional version of this problem ok
and one can prove that you can again get
a constant comparative constant
amortized algorithm here so here so far
we are ok but now when you want to
convert this into an integral solution I
mean just a simple randomized rounding
or standard algorithm it's not clear how
to bound the extent of reassignment so
so what we do is that for small sizes we
show that one can do randomized rounding
and for large jobs you need to do a
little bit more work but basically by
combining these two cases one get gets a
log log n algorithm ok and at the same
time we stay stay constant comparative
so let me show what else is known here
one can also talk about a more general
version where you want to maintain
maximum fair assignment so we can also
do that with constant comma constant in
both the parameters and and then one
interesting question is that for general
job sizes can one get a constant
reassignment constant comparative
algorithm so we don't know how to do
that another interesting question is it
seems that if you insist that at each
point of time let's you can only make
ten changes in your solution there
should be a lower bound but we don't
know how to prove such a thing okay
so yeah so in terms of the in the in the
non-inverted case it's very poorly
understood okay so the best we know is
that one can get a log log number of
reassignments per arrival and then one
can get a constant competitive but we
don't know if you can get a constant
comma constant no amortized result okay
let me finally talk about the okay so
then of course one can also ask the
question of fully dynamic setting that
jobs are also arriving and leaving so in
fact even for the edge of orientation we
don't understand this problem so we
don't know how to solve this yeah okay
finally let me talk about what is known
for the Steiner tree problem so remember
the question was that vertices arrived
one by one and you have to maintain a
standard tree here and when a new vertex
arrives you you could perhaps change
some of the edges in your existing tree
okay so for apps you could change this
tree
and so on okay now here's what is known
so amazing x-men showed that one can get
a constant competitive algorithm by
changing about Rutten edges at each
point of time then this was improved to
a pee test by me goeth and others where
they were doing about one over epsilon
log 1 over epsilon changes per vertex 11
okay we improved it to slightly 1 over
epsilon and and then 1 if you can get a
trade off here you can get a bigger
constant with a with a better
approximation here ok so you can get a
constant gamma constantly let me let me
show you what the idea is like any very
simple so we know that there is a greedy
algorithm which says that when a vertex
arrives you connected to the closest
vertex now this I know is it doesn't
have a good comparative ratio it is log
am competitive ok so now let's say that
besides doing this I do something else I
say that whenever you see two edges
let's say E and F F is in your tree and
E is not in your tree and suppose if I
could add a and remove F this the cost
of this tree goes down suppose I could
do these kind of changes ok so then I
will say that let's add a and remove F
ok and I keep on doing this now if I can
even do it doing this still I can do
this I know that this will lead to an
MST because that's exactly what it is
but we can show that this would lead to
a lot of changes okay so it's it's we
don't know we can show that you know
there's a lot of changes you will make
here but now you can say that if I only
want to Peters kind of result let's say
that you will swap a and F only if you
get somewhat significant benefit okay so
only if the length of e it's somewhat
smaller than the length of F ok and if
you keep on doing this again it's
possible to show that you will get a
tree whose cost as within 1 plus epsilon
of the optimum an interesting thing when
it's show is now the number of swaps
you're making is only a constant per
Ravin so here's one slight idea of the
proof the way the proof goes is the
following so let's let's say that's the
minimum spanning tree and this is your
tree I'll define a potential function ok
the potential function is the following
it says that look at the greedy solution
greedy is when remember greedy is a log
am competitive solution but let's look
at the product of all the edges in the
greedy solution okay and compare that
with the product of all these is in the
MST ok this quantity is never more than
four to the N so I mean I don't have a
simple proof of this but let's believe
this fact ok now if you if you look at
this statement I claim we are done why
because each time you do your swap what
are we doing we are reducing the
numerator by by some factor because
you're reducing replacing an edge by a
somewhat smaller edge okay so each swap
decreases a product by 1 over 1 plus
epsilon some constant factor and so you
cannot be doing this operation multiple
many times ok so yeah ok so I mean one
can ask interesting questions we show
that even if you allow vertices to be
deleted one can get a constant amortized
algorithm and in fact when you even get
such a result in the non amortized
sitting now in all of these cases where
so we have a result which which shows
that you can get a constant
comparatively even let's say you are
allowed let us say one change at each
point of time but this algorithm is much
more complicated we conjecture the
following should be true that let's say
at each point of time you see that I
should be making these hundred changes
but you put them in a queue and you say
that let me just pick the top 5 changes
ok so is this a constant competitive
algorithm which is you know which is
only doing five changes at each point of
time so it's a non amortized kind of
result so we don't know how to prove
this we don't know how to do the fully
dynamic case again if you're allowed
only constant number of changes at each
point of time and then one can ask a
similar question for other network
design problems standard forest
higher connectivity and so on this is
just a list of what other things are
known for traveling salesman problem one
can again get a constant comma constant
there's some work on Facility Location
recently we did we looked at set cover
where you say that points are arriving
or they could be moving away and we
showed that one can get a log log in
competitive constant recourse algorithm
so let me just conclude so online I'll
go through these records it's a powerful
tool which addresses some of these
shortcomings of competitive analysis in
some cases and it has there plenty of
open problems in in routing resource
allocation facility location
so there's been a lot of interest and
algorithms with predictions right so if
I have the option of seeing K time steps
into the future or changing K of my
previous actions do you have a sense
which one is the more powerful model yes
so there is some work on look ahead
where you say that I'll have some look
ahead and maybe I'll use that but I
don't know how to compare the two yeah I
don't have a sense of that